[Music]
from the nation's capital the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research presents public policy forums a
series of programs featuring the
nation's top authorities presenting
their differing views on the vital
issues which confront us
today's topic weapons against inflation
unless you're a visitor just in from
outer space or perhaps you've been
living on a desert island somewhere
you've noticed that the cost of living
has gone up tremendously over the last
several months to the point where today
it costs twice as much to buy goods and
services as it did to buy the same
things just twelve years ago President
Carter's voluntary anti-inflation
program is aimed at cooling the
inflationary fires but will it work what
are the alternatives how great is the
possibility of a recession sometime
during 1979 if it comes how serious will
it be is the president likely to ask for
and perhaps received permission from
Congress perhaps even standby permission
to invoke mandatory wage and price
controls in the near future and what was
our experience the last time the country
had mandatory economic controls some of
the country's biggest companies have
promised to go along with a Carter
anti-inflation program but what about
labor
especially with major contract
negotiations in the works during 1979
welcome to another public policy forum
presented by AEI the American Enterprise
Institute a nonprofit nonpartisan
research and education organization this
roundtable discussion will explore the
topic weapons against inflation
appearing on our panel today are alfred
econ chairman of the Council on wage and
price stability dr. Cohn with a PhD in
economics from Yale University is
counselor to the president for inflation
mr. Carter's chief inflation fighter
before taking over as the man in charge
of the voluntary wage and price control
program dr. Khan head of the Civil
Aeronautics Board where he helped bring
about airline deregulation alan
greenspan
former chairman of the President's
Council of Economic Advisers under
President Gerald Ford dr. green spends
PhD in economics is from New York
University he is presently president of
an economics consulting firm Townsend
Greenspan in New York City dr. Greenspan
has held numerous government positions
including the chairmanship of four White
House economic committees Rudolph a
Oswald is director of research for the
National Labor Organization the afl-cio
he is a former Fulbright Scholar who
holds a PhD also in economics from
Georgetown University dr. Oswald has
devoted much of his professional career
researching the effect of the nation's
economy on the well-being of American
workers
Marvin custer's is a resident scholar at
AEI and director of its Center for the
Study of government regulation he too
holds a PhD in economics from the
University of Chicago
dr. custer's has served as senior staff
economist to the President's Council of
Economic Advisers and as deputy
assistant to the president for Economic
Affairs during the Ford administration
he spent three years as associate
director of the president's
cost-of-living Council John Charles
Daley will moderate today's roundtable
discussion mr. Daley is a former News
correspondent and commentator for CBS
News and ABC News he is a former ABC
Network vice president and once headed
the voice of America now here is mr.
Daley this public policy forum part of a
series presented by the American
Enterprise Institute is concerned with
what may well be called the Enigma of
free societies inflation for nearly a
decade and a half we have been
struggling with an inflationary economy
at home while keeping a wary eye on the
often dramatic struggles with inflation
by our colleagues in the industrial and
developing societies abroad there is the
sense that as with the common cold we're
not sure
inflation came from or what we should or
can do about it
at the beginning of 1978 the
administration initiated a voluntary
program under which government business
and labor would cooperate in an anti
inflation program inspired by persuasion
and publicity the results have been less
than inspiring at the end of 1978 the
administration issued an urgent call to
battle the president outlined a new plan
of attack which in his words will cut
the budget deficit slash federal hiring
and reduced the federal workforce
restrained federal pay delay further tax
cuts removed needless regulations use
federal policy to encourage more
competition set specific standards for
both wages and prices throughout the
economy generally limiting wage
increases to 7% and price increases to
five and three-quarters percent and the
president concluded we will use all the
powers at our disposal to make this
program work announcing that legislative
proposals to implement elements of the
program would go to the Congress in
January the president highlighted his
surprise weapon a real wage insurance
proposal as an additional incentive for
labor cooperation workers who observe
the wage standards in the program would
be eligible for a tax rebate if the
inflation rate is more than seven
percent these then as of now and if the
Congress approves new legislation are
the principle weapons in our Arsenal
against inflation dr. Khan the president
said in a press conference recently
obviously with more than a thousand
different kinds of decisions to be made
there will be some flexibility do you
and the president anticipate any major
modifications now that you've heard from
many constituencies during the legally
mandated public comment period just
concluded I don't think one could
characterize the kinds of modifications
that we're thinking about as major but
there are two kinds
we are very intensively considering the
first is in response to an almost
unanimous criticism by business as well
as labor that our treatment of fringe
benefits and in particular the ketchup
costs of maintaining existing levels of
benefits is simply too stringent and
therefore we are contemplating a number
of possible ways of introducing a
modicum of flexibility in treating them
the second is in response to the obvious
point that's been made by labor but it
was made by me and testimony back in
1971 that a standard that permits the
passon of uncontrollable costs with a
fixed percentage margin permits
accumulation of profits on the basis of
additional costs and we're trying to
devise ways of preventing the earning of
additional profits on additional costs
alright dr. Greenspan
what are the similarities and
differences between President Carter's
new program and President Ford's win
program
[Music]
well if I can expand President Ford's
win program into two parts one a call
for severe restriction on fiscal policy
federal spending and on the budget
deficit and the other something of a
vague freeze I would say there is quite
a good deal similar with the same
problems in my view all that is
desirable and in fact all that is
necessary to restrain inflation is in
the first part of both of those programs
that is the restraint on federal
government expenditure and indirectly on
its credit creating capacities the
second part namely the guidelines I
think are counterproductive actually are
not a part of an anti inflation program
but in my view actually ultimately add
to inflation so I would suspect that the
guideline part was wholly inappropriate
response to inflation under the name
Wynn and I would suspect I would come
out pretty much the same with that part
of President Carter's program they're
both losers all right dr. Oswald will
you we've already had reference to it
will you summarize organized Labor's
objections toward the administration
program organized Labor's objections are
that it's described as a voluntary
program but it really is mandatory in
terms of wages because there is an
enforcement mechanism there which is
every employer is willing to enforce a
set guideline of 7%
contrary to what you said in your
introduction there's not a five and
three quarter percent guideline on
prices as a matter of fact the only
mention of a price guideline is nine and
a half percent and it talks about a half
a percent deceleration from the sort of
price increases that took place in 1976
1977
that says those who raise prices the
most can do so again and those who were
most responsible at that time can do
less now that hardly seems like an
equitable program because it means that
there is not really a mechanism for
controlling prices because there's no
manpower to do it and the consumer
doesn't know what an appropriate price
increase is and no other source of
income is controlled except wages and
that's the basic objection and therefore
the labor movement said if there are to
be controls let's make them by
legislation effectively enforced against
everybody so that they apply effectively
against all segments of the economy not
just against workers who are working for
wages all right dr. Costas you have
served with the Council of Economic
Advisers as associate director of the
cost of living Council and authored
controls and inflation the economic
stabilization program in retrospect so
you have been in this battlefield for a
long time do you think the president's
voluntary program would work I think
that there are two ways of addressing
that question the first way would be to
ask is it likely to break down and by
breaking down I mean will there happen
to be a wage increase or possibly even a
price increase somewhere that seems so
much out of line what are set out as the
standards that the whole program gets
discredited now that's a tendency under
any program the program that I was
involved in we said those were the last
cows in the barn but one can do that
only about so long and it wears a little
bit thin so that's always a risk and
there are good reasons for it the second
way to address the question is to ask is
the rate of inflation likely to be lower
after it's all over with than it was
before well by virtue of the the
standards themselves I would say that's
quite unlikely we have a great deal of
experience with that both in Europe and
in the United States all of that
experience that I'm aware of is negative
and I see no reason why we're like
fare any better under this one all right
but now let's come to grip with the
weapons against inflation
dr. Herbert Stein whom we all know has
had a great deal of experience with
inflation and its problems has written
of the last decade of our struggles with
inflation quote two lessons of this
recent history are relevant today one do
not think we can flirt with controls and
not get them and to do not think that
the ineffectiveness of controls which
has roots deep in the American economic
and political system can be overcome by
sufficiently enthusiastic operators I'll
say you to that would you respond dr.
John well it's a little difficult to
know where to begin
the notion that any kind of controls or
incomes policy is can only do harm it
seems to me can only spring from an
assumption that the level at which let's
say the Teamsters sign for a wage
increase is somehow god-given or
competitive market determined in the
same way as let's say the free price of
natural gas if it were uncontrolled I
submit that there's an enormous
difference between those two if you hold
the price of natural gas below its
marginal cost you're gonna get shortages
is there anybody on this panel who
believes that if you can induce the
Teamsters by one device or another to
reduce their wage settlement from eleven
percent to ten to nine to eight to seven
percent that you're gonna have a
shortage of Teamsters that this is a
competitive market which by University
of Chicago - god-given standards should
not be interfered with I submit that's
an absurdity now I'm not suggesting that
that the that these weapons are total
and I'm not as you know an enthusiastic
supporter of the guidelines I have been
quoted correctly as referring to them as
those stinking wage price guidelines I
don't love them but on the other hand I
do not believe
is logical to speak of a lot of these
prices and wages as though they are
determined in a competitive market so in
such a way that to interfere will
produce enormous distortions in the
economy I won't go on a great length
there's a lot of differences from the
wind program which which alone attracted
me to this one difference is that we
don't have any ties yet which have win
on the notion that all the agora
European experience is negative is I
submit a piece of folklore the British
experience does suggest that it is
possible by having some sort of incomes
policy if you have a sufficient
acceptance of the notion that we are in
a process of mutual frustration if that
becomes sufficiently widespread that you
can in fact at least four periods of
time and do certain restraints it is not
an accident that every Western
democratic capitalist country has
attempted in one way or another to grope
for incomes policy conclusion I am not
at all suggesting that this is the part
of the program that turns me on I'm not
suggesting that it would do any good in
the absence of monetary and fiscal
restraints and I wish you would all
mention the fact that we have a very
comprehensive intention at least to
attack structural defects in the economy
and government interventions that
inflate costs and prevent competition
but I think what you've really described
as a Controls program which you have
attempted to put into effect on the wage
side without any legal basis for putting
it into effect which in a sense denies
the appropriate procedure by which
issues can be handled there should be an
appropriate body which has sufficient
manpower to hear cases there should be a
legal basis for punishing those that
don't appear rather than by some vague
threats which don't really have a legal
basis where you attempt to use laws not
for the purpose for which they were
designed but for other purposes and if
the inflation is really as bad as it is
if we're going to have these sorts of
things then let's do it right let's do
it by law let's do it equitably would
you elucidate on what you mean by using
laws and met in a way other than they
are intended to be used well the
president indicated that in order to
enforce his guidelines I believe that's
the words that he used he was going to
use government procurement actions he
was going to use the actions of the
export-import bank and since then he's
made allusions to other laws as a basis
for trying to make sure that there is
compliance those laws all were
established with specific goals in terms
of but providing for government
procurement for providing for aiding
American exports abroad a number of
other things if we're going to have a
program that is geared towards inflation
why not set up a law that deals with
that directly rather than through this
indirect fashion then would you like to
speak well I'll be very brief when a
lawyer tells me that I'm not following
due process I tend to look hold on to my
wallet when an economist tells me I but
the same thing I'm going to hold on to
my checkbook as well I'm not an expert
on the law our lawyers tell us that it
is perfectly reasonable for the
government to use its regulatory
authority to refuse for example to pass
on inordinate wage or cost increases and
I'm not a lawyer so I I guess take it up
with my priest chaplain was the word I
was groping for I presume they were not
referring to me in that
oh I'd never make that mistake I'd like
to go back to there's some very
important and really fundamental
questions which dr. Khan raised right in
the beginning I think that we will get
back to dr. Oswald's issue because
that's going to proliferate this
discussion extensively
I agree the Teamsters do not strike me
as a union characterized by extreme
competition I would not I would not
therefore be that diplomatic different I
would not therefore conclude that the
solution to the problem is guidelines I
think that there are obviously far more
effective and long-run solutions to that
problem such as deregulating the
trucker's which working through the
market mechanism I think would do have
surprising impact on the the Teamsters
themselves the question as to whether or
not the European experience is valid or
not is a extremely difficult one I tend
to conclude pretty much the way dr.
Coasters comes out but I will grant you
that it is extraordinarily difficult to
read some of that evidence I would say
the hypothesis that stipulates that they
work is extremely difficult to
demonstrate and I personally believe
impossible although I will grant you the
opposite is also rather difficult the
reason I believe that democratic
societies grope for this type of
mechanism when confronted with inflation
is that it perceives this sort of
approach as creating some form of
short-term political benefit and in
certain instances it does I don't deny
for example that President Nixon's
freeze in August of 1971 did in fact
stop the rate of inflation but the
problem that we have is that while there
is as pressure for short-term benefits
there is a growing unawareness of the
longer term
costs that such policies invariably
generate and one of our difficulties
that we have in societies like ours is
that politicians the political system as
a whole tends to overemphasize
short-term benefits in virtually all of
its actions without fully comprehending
the long-term costs and I believe that
one of the major problems that
guidelines controls mandatory or non
mandatory create is they give the
illusion of success and they do in fact
create problems far greater than I think
we conceivably imagined we've had many
problems in this area one of the more
recent examples of the difficulty is
that the legacy of the Nixon control
program is created for us namely the
problem in oil and energy price controls
and the difficulties that are emerged to
have emerged in unleaded gasoline and in
a number of other areas I submit that
what we tend to create are huge
bureaucratic systems which essentially
shuffle paper and cannot very easily be
demonstrated to have significant impacts
on the overall price or wage level
overall I would tend to argue that in
the longer run because they thought
productivity because they generate
imbalances in the system they tend the
long-run to be pro inflation rather than
anti-inflation clusters you won't take a
shot - yeah well that I think it's
important to recognize that whenever you
have a set of standards whether
voluntary or mandatory there one piece
of policy in the context of all of the
policies that are going on this of
course is what makes it difficult to
assess the impact of any given program
at any time take for example the British
case it is true that inflation came down
while the policy was in force but it's
also true that the
good deal of belt-tightening going on
when the policy was implemented and I
think that the fact that other policies
are being made at the same time and that
they're being made in the context of the
fact that there is a program of
standards creates one of the the main
dangers of such a program
back when the 1971-72 and so on controls
were in force it was often said that the
controls helped to make it possible to
have a more vigorous expansion than we
could otherwise have at the present time
it's often said that we need to make a
choice between voluntary controls if
they are not successful perhaps between
mandatory controls and recession and it
seems to me that when one is talking
about that kind of choice one is talking
about perhaps stimulating the economy
somewhat more than what otherwise be
considered prudent and that seems like a
formula for more inflation rather than
less inflation from everything we know
could I just respond very briefly to
that I think this is very useful in
narrowing the the controversy between us
in some cases to a point where there is
no controversy the there's no question
that when the mandatory controls were
imposed in August of 1971 in
anticipation of an election 15 months
ahead and of course I'm not impugning
the motives of the Republicans anymore
than the Democrats who would have done
the same thing if they were in power nor
suggesting that history will repeat
itself free saitama
you have taken the words exactly out of
my mouth
the imposition of controls at that time
was obviously part of a deliberate
attempt to inflate the economy and for
obvious reasons we were making
unsatisfactory progress in reducing
unemployment and it was thought that if
you could impose the controls then you
could have massive monetary expansion
and and budgetary looseness and the one
was a attempt to make it possible to do
the other but we are talking now about a
context in which limitations are being
imposed macro restraint is being
followed and it is simply an
unwillingness on the part of the gun
country and I are the government and I
think the country to rely exclusively on
us on a jamming out of the monetary and
fiscal brakes the the distortions it
seems to me arm are far less likely to
be serious than they were in the context
of 71 to 73 though I do not look forward
to a permanent continuation that
controls any more enthusiasm than you do
you do mr. speaker Greenspan doctor
whether or not we turn out to be in
difficulty a year from now will depend
largely on what happens to monetary and
fiscal policy in the meantime just as it
did then I think it's important to look
at the change in the situation at that
time we had an inflation rate of a
little bit over 4% now the inflation
rate is over nine and a half percent at
that time food prices were relatively
stable food prices now are going up at a
twelve and a half percent rate and they
are a major factor in what consumers buy
the interest rates have been going up
substantially which has been pushing up
the housing sectors substantially and
the cost of housing medical care then
was going up rapidly is still going up
rapidly and energy costs at that time
we're not yet shot off by the OPEC
situation and are going up rapidly now
and are expected to go up rapidly in the
next few years unless there is some sort
of an intervention and monetary and
fiscal policy will not address the
problems of food price increases will
not address directly the sec toriel
problems that exist and I think this
just say that there is some sort of
cosmetic here in terms of wage price
guidelines plus the strong monetary and
fiscal program is going to take care of
our inflation really doesn't look at
some of the pressures in different
segments of the economy which are
pushing up the price level much more
rapidly you know it basically concerns
me is that his program will be get yours
and the reason I say that is that I
think it's unrealistic to presume that
you can have a stable equilibrium type
guidelines program this is not a stable
program and if it increases what will
start to occur it will begin to find
that any even skillfully crafted program
of guidelines or standards must of
necessity be comprehensible in a
political sense which means it can
scarcely pick up more than at best 95
percent of all of the possible types of
wage and price decisions that wouldn't
be made which is terrific except that
there were a hundred million of them out
there which means you're dealing with
five million decisions as an example
which go outside the guidelines as you
start to try to bring them in you begin
to get an extraordinary burgeoning
system which ultimately I fear is going
to be sanctioned by the Congress as a
mandatory system because it will have
all the characteristics except the
authorizing legislation on the question
of the Rises and energy prices and food
prices I would agree with this side of
the table which is well from your point
of view on the right
totally that the solution for rising
energy prices is not mandatory price
control the solution for the rising
price of beef is not mandatory price
controls or any kind of price controls
and and I think therefore to the extent
that you really are getting into a
situation in which you're not
influencing what is a real margin of
administrative discretion but you really
are trying to set price below some sort
of equilibrium point
you are simply concealing from consumers
what the real marginal cost of those
supplies is to the economy and I do
think that way lies disaster the part of
the program however that I find terribly
attractive is and again I recognize the
difference between promise and
performance that we are attempting
systematically to look at these
particular sectors which have been
responsible for the preponderance of the
increase in the cost of living and to
try to identify the restrictions on
competition the the insanities of
methods of organizations such as the
insane method that we have for paying
for medical care the interferences with
the free market such as we have as part
of our agricultural policy or our
regulation on trucking which until
recently required that you take your
trucks into a food store full and take
them back empty I mean in each of these
areas if you look at building codes and
land use restrictions and and inadequate
taxes on land that's held out of use
there are millions of things that can be
done in these areas but the thing that I
think should not and I I would suggest
that the people on my left would
probably approve of those attacks but I
suggest that the attempt to substitute
total controls to hold down the price of
oil when the incremental cost of the US
economy is $14 a barrel is in the long
run just a disaster it seems to me that
you could probably make a case for
saying that with a 7 percent wage
guideline there will be a lot of
business firms I do have an incentive to
try to enforce that on the other hand
with a voluntary price guideline like
there is which is a big price index it's
an enormous ly complicated thing to
audit or even to compute
it'd be difficult to determine just how
much compliance there is so in that
context it seems to me that if one
feared the possibility that the wage
guidelines would bite more than the
price guidelines that you would very
much favor a reduction in the increases
in a good demand that we've been having
in order to avoid the prospect that
wages will tend to be held down and
prices will tend to float upward with a
fairly buoy and demand doctor a
reduction Negra demand is not an
assurance that will have reductions in
prices and it's that our concern is that
what we really will have is a
compounding of the problem we'll have a
continuation of very high inflation at
the same time that we will be pushed
towards what is it a banana and that the
pressure towards pushing the economy
towards a recession as a result of the
tight monetary and fiscal policies will
be severe so that we may have a
recession as well as inflation at the
same time may I because our time is
limited come to grips ask you to come to
grips with some of the specifics of the
program as it's been announced let's go
to real wage insurance doctor can I find
the real wage insurance plan a very
attractive and imaginative one would you
outline it for the television yes the
the general notion is that workers who
will settle for wage increases within
the 7% standard in a sense making an act
of faith that they will not suffer in
consequence from a failure of others to
follow will be insulated against an
increase in the cost of living beyond 7
percent by having a tax rebate for the
difference between the 7 percent at
which they settle and whatever the
cost-of-living increase is it's a
variant on the tax incentive plans which
try to build in to the tax system a
certain incentive to behave in a
socially responsible way in an area
which is not subject the perfect
competent
that presupposes that the reporting that
will be made by the extraordinary
numbers of millions of reports will be
accurate I think we know in advance the
way the system works that it will be
biased and biased in a very specific way
so that it's quite conceivable to me
that you can have the Bureau of Labor
Statistics report in an 8 or 9 percent
wage increase and have everybody
reporting that they complied under 7
percent that is not something which I
find utterly shocking I can't really
assess that perhaps you have some basis
yes no our experience with that type of
reporting when there is a reason to
report for certain in certain manner
very significantly biases the numbers
that's gonna say first of all that it
superficially looks like a very
attractive plant it has a very nice ring
to it I think the more you look at it in
detail the worse it looks at least so it
seems to me one reason for that is that
you have a wide variety of sizes the
wage increases that occur every year
take for example in 1977 first year wage
increases of major unions averaged about
8 percent but about 30 percent of the
people getting increases under those
agreements got increases the less than 7
percent about 20 percent got increases
on more than 9 percent so that about 30
percent under such a scheme might well
get some real wage insurance for a large
number of other people who got wage
increases they wouldn't really have any
interest in this program that just
allows them to keep up with inflation
when they could probably do better in
their own bargaining so I think that it
has a very haphazard kind of
distributional consequence in that
regard what also makes it I think
extremely difficult is the kind of
information that you would need to have
reported if you were going to pursue
assess the scheme and all the
complexities would have to be spelled
out in sufficient detail so that every
IRS auditor would be able to take a look
the situation like they do individual
income tax returns now well I'd be only
brief because I will shortly exhaust my
mind of information on the subject are
the Treasury experts assure us that
there's no no significant difficulty in
that kind of reporting on new contracts
it would be necessary to have some sort
of a certification by the Commission on
wage and price stability but I had
understood that you for years were in
the business of certifying whether a
settlement did or did not fall within
certain guidelines I'm not making a
debating point you may be exaggerating
now I just wanna make that last point I
think the Treasury is oversimplifying
what they're basically saying is that
you take an average earnings figure the
difficulty is that you have a mixed
problem difficulties of knowing whether
you're looking at a promotion or whether
you're looking at a wage increase you
have a problem of part-time workers you
have a problem of bonus workers I may be
the only private employer on this panel
and I would be very hesitant to sign
that w-2 form because I'm a terribly
certain whether the raises I give are in
fact a wage increase promotion or what
and that's true of most or a very
substantial part of small business and a
very substantial part of non-union labor
I think it's a I think it's a
tremendously complex program which we're
only seeing the tip of an iceberg and I
suspect the complexities of this issue
are going to baffle us I think for the
layman there is one question which all
four of you could help us with we are
not necessarily very understanding of
highly technical terms but we have
certain means in recent times
particularly heard so much about
monetary policy as a as a principal and
most effective weapon against inflation
do you is there agreement that did it
should have a greater weight than other
programs or is it just equal to fiscal
policy dr. Greenspan
I think what we know is
when you have excessive monetary growth
you invariably have inflation and vice
versa and so that I would say yes money
supply is very critical but I would not
merely focus on it as something you can
turn on and off because it too is very
critically determined by other things in
my view before you can get a grip on
money supply growth and hence on
inflation you've got to reduce the
aggregate credit requirements in the
economy meaning you've got to reduce the
federal borrowing requirements which
comes from the budget deficit from off
budget financing you've got to reduce
the credit requirements which the
federal government indirectly requires
of the private sector by mandating
certain regulations on safety and
environment which they must borrow
against to meet I think the federal
government in many of its grants and aid
program induces state local governments
to borrow finally I think the most
important thing at this particular stage
is the tremendous expansion in the
mortgage market which has occurred in
large part as a consequence of
government subsidy direct and indirect
and that is what's creating a money
supply problem at this particular point
and unless we can come to grips with
that particular problem I do not I do
not envisage the federal reserve being
capable of restraining the growth and
money supply to non-inflationary
dimensions without creating an explosive
increase in interest rates dr.osman I
think I just wanted to amplify a little
bit what you've said Allen because I
think some of the money is now being
used for corporate mergers it's being
used for the expansion of maybe some of
the new gambling activities and New
Jersey and other places things that in
that sense are not the new production
that leads to things and it may be more
of shifting a round of money than demand
for goods and services and
and I'm not sure that the traditional
Federal Reserve Board actions get at
some of the credit creation that has
taken place through new means of
creating credit through the stock
markets options markets through futures
markets through all sorts of new means
of creating credit and I'm not sure that
we're really addressing that outside of
just raising interest rates that I think
is fairly harmful for a number of people
within the economy I would like to
suggest gentlemen we have put down a
very broad base on the administration's
program and the entire subject and it's
time for us to move to the question and
answer session in the past 30 years this
country has gone through six recessions
what steps is Congress likely to take to
prevent another one will federal budget
cuts do the trick at what point will we
risk a recession aside from mandatory
wage and price controls what should
Congress and the president be planning
for such an emergency now to challenge
our panel members let's get the views of
the experts in our audience all right
may I have the first question please
Larry Rosenberg National Science
Foundation the question is addressed to
the panel at lodge but perhaps first
professor Kahn
many of the suggested solutions to
inflation are of a longer-term
structural nature particularly seemingly
the suggestions to make markets more
efficient and more competitive within
that realm do you see any possibilities
for shorter range targets well the
targets will be very short range I
expect within the course of the year
that will there will be definite
movements in the direction of the
deregulation of trucking for example the
more thorough deregulation of the
railroads there will be active
discussions of the extent to which we
can have more competition in the
maritime shipping field rather than move
toward tighter and tighter Karla's ation
the area of agricultural restrictions on
output now you know don't expect the
Millennium
but certainly one can move in the
direction always of the less restrictive
approach toward maintaining farm income
trade restrictions after all the
president just vetoed that cotton
textiles protective legislation he
vetoed the beef quota bill that would
have tied his hands more perhaps that
gives you enough I mean we're interested
in the state regulation of insurance I
mean do you know for example that in the
states in which you have opened filing
that is more of a possibility of price
competition that you have markedly lower
insurance rates for liability and
property insurance than you have in
other states there's a whole it's kind
of a general attitude toward every way
in which the government subsidizes and
protects and limits competition and I
expect to produce a result yes doctor I
don't see that this is really a change
from what government has tried to do
always in terms of trying to affect the
economy and in terms of results I don't
anticipate that there will be results in
the next twelve months from these types
of programs well I look I don't promise
miracles but we had an airline
regulation system for 40 years and we
changed it this year maybe people will
learn that it's not so horrible after
all we can make more money we can we can
bring bargains to travelers we can even
have a three percent reduction in price
at the time when the CPI went up 7
percent I think that's a terribly
important example next question please
yes sir I'm John Kendrick of George
Washington University and my question is
primarily for Rudy Oswald in view of the
preponderance of labor costs in price do
you think it's possible to wind down
inflation without reducing the rate of
increase in wage rates or average hourly
compensation and if you agree with that
let me ask you how would you recommend
that we gradually decelerate the rate of
increase in wage rates in the economy
dr. Kendrick I think that you've written
many books on the impact of productivity
in the economy and the ability to have
real gains in the economy as a result of
tivity well part of the gains of
productivity can be used to slow down
productivity when I spoke before in
terms of dr. Khan's notion of looking at
sectoral problems I think that there are
certain sectoral problems that can be
addressed that are not directly wage
related and in general wage changes in
the last year the last three years have
not been particularly pressing in terms
of pushing prices up there have been
substantial attempts to catch up but
that's an attempt to say that when
somebody works he expects to be able to
have the ability to purchase something
with what he works for rather than just
paper I just say one word about it I
have no intention of putting ascribing
blame particularly to one part of the
economy or another but you really have
missed the basic arithmetic point that
dr. Kendrick made that if 70 percent of
your sales prices or of your gross
national product goes to labor then
there's absolutely no way in the world
in which you can have wage increases of
10 11 9 or even 7 percent a year when we
have never come remotely close on any
long-range basis to producing
productivity increases of more than
three and now we're more nearly at the
2% level without getting something like
giving those different examples six
seven eight percent of inflation per
year and that's the simple answer to his
question there is no way and I guess
that's that's a matter of simple
arithmetic the other point I wanted to
make was catch up you will always find
at least 50 percent of the population
who have not done as well in a preceding
year is the other 50 percent actually if
you know the way these frequency
distributions are spread it's more than
50 percent to do less well than average
if you always always say anybody who is
falling behind has a right to catch up
then you have built in a permanent
engine of inflation catch up equals
inflation target question I certainly
agree with the point on arithmetic that
is there is no way in which you can get
inflation to slow down without having
menstruates slowdown in the rate of wage
increase but as I understand this
program something more is intended and
that is if I understood Fred kind
correctly or earlier what you saying is
that the program plans to look at
situations where competition in the
labor market is less prevalent now it
seems to me that that makes sense if you
can induce the institutional change that
makes the situation more competitive but
to use wage controls or wage standard or
some kind of wage price policy to get a
result that you would not get with the
conditions of competition in that
industry in that sector I think is
likely to fail but I think this is so
important that I forgive me for another
second please do we're asking where are
the signs of excessive aggregate demand
too much spending in the economy that is
pushing wages up and we see very little
signs of that in most parts of the
economy you may say it's there's
excessive spending for housing and yet
construction wages have risen much less
than the average and my answer is that
the basic problem of inflation is a
social problem it is a mark of a society
in which people are constantly
increasing their income claims both in
the wages they demand in the profit
margins on which that they add to their
wage cost in the demands that they place
on government for tax preferences or
subsidies in the demands for government
spending programs they all add up to
more than we can supply at constant
prices and that's what we've been
witnessing it's justified by some on the
grounds of catch-up it's justified by
others on the ground that there in
industries which are above average and
productivity
what we see then is a problem that it
seems to us is not easily solvable
simply by putting Mack aggregate
restraints because that will cause great
unemployment it's simple enough to throw
twenty million people out of work and
then they will moderate their wage
demands we have to do something by way
of inducing a general spirit of social
discipline which alone can come in my
judgment only by a recognition that
we're we're all like hamsters in a cage
running as fast as we can and staying in
the same place and that we I think
there's a general recognition that we've
all got a moderate in some way and I
don't know how to do that by simply
imposing monetary and fiscal restraints
without serious unemployment
let me just answer that very briefly
Kostas it seems to me that our problem
so far this year has not been a matter
of wages rising faster than prices or in
any sense pushing prices up it seems to
me clearly to not have come from the
side workers all saying to themselves we
can't fall behind that we got to catch
up or we got to do better instead it
seems to have come on the price side
that is to say prices have risen a good
deal more during the course of the year
then have wages it seems to me very
difficult to argue that that our problem
now is those costs pushing themselves up
autonomously rather than that it's
demand pushing prices up dr. Greenberg
the problem that we have got is one
which we have no firm theoretical
understanding of we have for the last
six or seven years been endeavoring to
understand the theoretical framework
which constructs a situation in which we
have chronic inflation in a period of
less than full utilization of resources
it is not an explanation to say that
there are excess demands in the social
system because that translated into the
mechanisms of an economy is a demand
pull situation the problem that we have
got is not something we fully understand
when we endeavor to create the
relationship of wages and prices in our
economic models we have found them
wholly inadequate we have been groping
for answers and I think at this stage
the results to date have been most
unsatisfactory I would not conclude from
that that therefore we then presume that
because we see a relationship between
wages and prices which does exist that
we can somehow treat the symptoms of the
problem and presume the issue will be
resolved I think the experience that we
have had in endeavoring to bring down
inflation by bringing down wages or
bringing down wages by bringing
prices invariably has failed and fallen
apart all that we can observe is that
these particular efforts at creating the
symptoms have not worked and I think
that to call for a particular form of
restraint which somehow simultaneously
will bring the whole system down
I think flies in the face of the
experiences that we and other countries
have had in this whole particular area
there has been one of the explanations
which is this issue of inflation and
expectations as though that explains the
phenomenon well it doesn't because the
mere fact of people expecting prices to
rise further will certainly induce them
to take certain actions but it's not
clear in which direction in fact our
experience when people are concerned
about inflation is that they don't spend
more they save more they can track their
actions which is actually an anti
inflationary force so that doesn't
explain it I think what we have is a
tremendously serious problem I am very
much concerned that we are we all grant
that there's some fundamental solutions
to this and we keep saying that we can't
we have to create 20 million unemployed
but that I find rather rhetorical to say
the least what concerns me is that we
know what the the problem is we say it
is politically socially and otherwise
unacceptable to do this that or the
other thing and we find that as we
procrastinate the problem gets worse and
the form of the socially and politically
unacceptable alternative gets worse
every year
I submit at some point we're going to
have to come to grips with this problem
and work very hard to resolve it and not
continuously look for solutions for
which there are no costs may I have the
next question
sir yes dance card feat Fairchild
publications when the president's
program was first announced he indicated
that the federal government would use
its purchasing power to encourage
compliance by not buying from
contractors who violated the guidelines
my question is are you moving toward
asking the nation's consumers to boycott
companies that violate the price
guidelines we haven't done so explicitly
and I'm sorry to say that I have not yet
reached the point of being able to give
you an adequate answer you must
recognize however that we what we have
is a program that is in very large
measure voluntary and is indeed being
enforced by something on the order of a
hundred people and we are determined to
fashion a program that which will not
require any more than 100 people there's
a tremendous amount of self enforcement
here now in those circumstances where
you're depending very largely on
volition and you're not going to have a
field of inspectors who are going to be
able to look at prices and individual
grocery stores or the rents charged or
the prices charged for haircuts I think
that that one very important enforcement
mechanism will have to be a kind of
sensitization of consumers to this
inflation and decisions by consumers not
to buy from people who are raising their
prices excessively well but I think
that's expecting something that the
guidelines don't even allow somebody to
know for example in November 16th
Newsweek magazine raised the price of
the magazine from a dollar to a dollar
and a quarter but there's no way of an
individual knowing whether that's in
compliance with the guidelines or not
and yet that's the 25 percent increase
in terms of a product that is sold on
the newsstands I think the expectation
that has been given by the president's
message is that there is a government
who is concern has set guidelines and
will do something and yet you tell them
on the wage side employers will do
something but on the price side nothing
will be done well I think that's absurd
I mean we don't have any authority any
more authority to do something about
wages in a particular locality then we
have to do about prices in that locality
so if you're going to talk about the
limitations of our enforcement
mechanisms they apply those limitations
apply both the wage in the price side
except that on the wage side you do have
an organized mechanism of enforcers
employers there is no organized group of
consumers oh that's not true please do
it right I think that the presumption
that employers somehow would like to
keep the wages down no matter what I
think
missus how wages are set in a non-union
area wages are set not by the
benevolence of the employer but by their
need to keep their good workers in place
producing the goods that they have to
sell to their customers if they
arbitrarily endeavour to restrain wages
below some particular market level they
would find a substantial part of their
most productive workforce going to their
competitors and I would think that that
view that somehow that the employers are
controlling the wages and are in fact
the wage enforces I think badly miss
reads how the system functions doctor
Costas I'd like to point out an oddity
about the way this kind of enforcement
mechanism works you have a situation
where the government is getting
procurement bids and so on and as I
understand it instead of taking the low
bid if that firm was out of compliance
because it granted a large wage
increases a large wage increase it would
take the higher bid it seems to me that
what we don't want to encourage is
behavior that has high prices and
doesn't raise wages very much and it
seems to me to be a mistake to encourage
consumers to to patronize that kind of
firm as well
alright this concludes another public
policy forum presented by the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research this public policy forum on
weapons against inflation has brought
you the views of four experts in the
field it was presented by AEI the
American Enterprise Institute it is the
aim of AEI to clarify issues of the day
by presenting many viewpoints in the
hope that by so doing those who wish to
learn about the decision-making process
will benefit from such a free exchange
of informed and enlightened opinion this
public policy forum series is created
and supplied to this station as a public
service by the American Enterprise
Institute Washington DC for a transcript
of this program send $3.75 to the
American Enterprise Institute 11:50 17th
Street Northwest Washington DC to 0 0 3
6